our sex organs were kind of like hands
or feet they were obedient and after
that after we ate the Apple did what we
did the sex organs to Augustine became
like little dictators that we have to
either succumb to or overpower hi I'm
Tracy Oppenheimer for recent TV and
today we're talking with Eric Berkowitz
author of sex and punishment 4000 years
of judging desire Eric thanks for
talking to us great to be here
what were some of the trends and
patterns you noticed and how society's
view certain sexual acts throughout the
history you followed for millennia quite
a few trends exist by society's looking
to morals laws and sex laws in order to
define themselves and very often they
define themselves as not being like
someone else and very very often
accusations of immorality or perversion
or sexual transgression are made against
enemies it's very common to accuse your
enemies of being homosexual or being
sexually perverted so that was a common
very very common accusation made against
Muslims by Christian Europe etc and as
the modern age dawned and as it took
shape very very often morals laws exist
as part of the sort of arsenal that
governments have to exert their control
over their citizenry I think I think
it's interesting you called an arsenal I
mean has historically why do you think
governments have always wanted to be you
know in control of what goes on in the
bedroom it's a variable it's a it's a
loose cannon in the human character that
I don't think a government can feel that
it really has control over its people
unless it has some modicum of control
over people's actions in the bedroom
religion has a lot to do with it and
also the fact that for lack of a better
word sex is just so important the first
laws that we have
written down came from ancient
Mesopotamia about 2,000 BC and the
collections have been translated and I
was looking at them and I noticed that
fully 1/3 of them had to do with
marriage sex adultery on and on and on
also of course because sexual activity
produces children and it produces
lineage by which to transfer property
etc etc that gets into property rights
contract rights and that's the basis of
civil law with religion and power let's
talk about original sin and how that
might have played a part in just the
corresponding acts of government and law
it played an immense part original sin
was really the creation of Saint Saint
Augustine who existed in the 4th century
AD and is one of the great Christian
fathers of he and a few others are
really responsible as much as anyone for
creating Christianity as we understand
it according to Augustine before we left
the Garden of Eden
our sex organs were kind of like hands
or feet they were obedient and after
that after we ate the Apple did what we
did the sex organs to Augustine became
like little dictators that we have to
either succumb to or overpower so all
creation human creation was to him and
became church doctrine an emblem of evil
if you will and that denial of the
sexual urge that almost criminalization
of it led toward the strong Christian a
version to the sexual urge and here we
are 2,000 years years later with a
legacy of sexual denial that when you
think sex is bad you make bad sex laws
and and that province the province of
reproduction family became the province
of the church the church after the fall
of Rome grew in power immensely and
became the orchestrating factor for sex
law and and I think we're still fighting
it what are some of the other behaviors
sexual behaviors that have been targeted
over time and the cultures he studied oh
there's so many one of which which is
interesting always is his prostitution
which has been dealt with in a hundred
different ways over the years and it's
now shockingly as big an issue as ever
traditionally prostitution was never
illegal it was it was taxed it was a
profession let's go back to Augustine
and the Catholic Church well I think it
was a surprise to a lot of the readers
of my book that the church itself was
involved in the prostitution business
for a very very long time and cities why
because there was money to be made
what's the justification well we need
prostitutes to protect good women the
city of Florence had a city run brothel
back then in the 15th century Florentine
men weren't getting married to other
late 20s that was the tradition a lot
like today and the city said at the
brothel on the justification that it
would get boys interested in girls and
it might keep them from becoming
homosexual so now where do we stand
prostitution is going on as much as ever
but it's now digital in a lot of ways
which implicates a whole new range of
laws and we now have the sex negativism
of both the far right and the far left
viewing all prostitutes as victims all
customers as slave holders and I'm not
using that word in advising Lea that
that word is used and all press
prostitution
Trent transactions as being like
trafficking when you have the belief
that all prostitution at its core is
rape and all prostitution at its core is
enslavement then you begin to
criminalize the trade much much more and
you begin to drive it underground much
much more and you begin to in effect
expose the women to further danger than
they would
in before we also have had very big
changes in how we view children very big
changes and they're both good and bad I
think if Roman Polanski the film
director had been caught a hundred years
earlier
with a 13 year old girl he would have
there wouldn't have been a legal issue
at all in the 19th century the average
age of consent for sexual activity was
12
many states 10 some one seven we also
had very much much lower marriage ages
so there was a lot of sex with children
as we think of them now going on either
in marriage or informally that wasn't
illegal have we gone too far in the
other direction yeah I think that too by
making the age of consent 18 as it is
now in California you turn a lot of
people into sex criminals who shouldn't
be you're working on a book right now
that yeah related to modern times and
I'm wondering are we approaching more
the final frontier of sexual freedom I
would have thought so I really would
have
I mean I'm 53 I was born in the late 50s
in the course of my life I've seen some
pretty amazing things and and you would
think that we would finally be reaching
a point where society's concerns would
turn towards more substantial things I
don't claim to be working in the most
substantial subject in the world but as
the 2012 election showed that's really
not the case
we now have in my lifetime in the in the
early 80s there's a new field of law
that's become a huge industry for
lawyers like myself which is sex
harassment in the workplace that is an
industry that is a large large aspect of
civil litigation why is that because it
makes some people quite a bit of money
with every final frontier there's a new
one opening up so I don't think morals
and morals laws is
are leaving the national conversation
anytime soon that was really interesting
thank you so much for talking to us
great talking with you freezin TV I'm
Tracy Oppenheimer